hey guys welcome back so you all know
the saying how do you get to Carnegie
Hall practice right everybody knows you
need to practice to improve on your
instrument but rarely do I hear anyone
talking about how to practice so today I
thought it'd be fun to give you some
advice that I really wish I would have
gotten when I was learning how to play
the guitar here are five common practice
mistakes
[Music]
people quit playing the guitar everyday
because they hit a wall decide they must
have no talent and give up but more
often than not their lack of progress is
due to poor and aimless practicing
habits not because you know their hands
are too small or they lack talent or
whatever other excuses we tell ourselves
so here are five common practice
mistakes that I really wish I knew when
I was learning guitar slowing down in
music is equivalent to zooming in on a
painting it allows you to see finer
detail and it's true that actually if
you play something very slow it might
actually sound worse because it
highlights and exposes your weaknesses
but if we're serious about improving on
the guitar which I hope you are then
step number one is exposing our greatest
weaknesses so that we can fix them when
I was learning electric guitar
I was so guilty of this first mistake of
playing too fast I used to just loop the
same riff or song again and again a
thousand times at the same speed and I
thought it was helping me but in fact
all it did was ingrained
bad habits into my muscle memory and
probably annoy the hell out of my
freshman year roommate I remember when I
was 17 I was obsessed with this one
technique called sweet picking it's
basically like an ascending arpeggio
done in one clean motion and I tried
that for countless hours but I always
practiced it at that exact same speed
and let's just say it didn't go well
[Music]
so if you're like I was and are tempted
to always play fast the simplest cure is
to just get a metronome it is the
easiest way to keep yourself in time
there's never been an easier time to use
one as well because there's dozens of
free apps I use one called pro metronome
on my phone and you can start by just
turning it on to something like 60 BPM
100 per second and this will force you
to play slower the other reason you need
to make the metronome your buddy is
because humans aren't born with good
rhythm it's a learned skill and so the
fingers by themselves want to rush or
slow down depending on how difficult
something is and the metronome can be
our robotic friend who kindly reminds us
where the real beat is
[Music]
so here is how I should have learned how
to sweep pick when I was 17 turn on the
metronome at something very slow 60 BPM
is always a good start each click is one
note that might seem very slow but it's
a luxury to play this slow because I
have time to think in between the notes
where's my finger going next
pinky ring finger our middle index pinky
when we're playing fast we have no time
to think about those things they just
have to be there so now that I'm playing
this slow I can focus on a few things
the first is can I actually match each
note with the metronome perfectly very
often I hear something like that when I
first show students a metronome
I was actually rushing rarely do people
go too slow they almost always rush so I
was ahead of the beats okay I'll try to
land on the other side of the beat I'll
go slower okay now I'm a little bit
behind now let's see if I can split the
difference and land rate with the
metronome okay that time I got it so
that's the type of practice that really
would have helped me learn how to sweet
pick at an early stage now of course
this has to go faster eventually so the
next thing I can do is bump up the tempo
to say 75 so we can bump it up in
increments of 15 beats per minute and we
decide to move up when it gets very easy
when we know we can do it every single
time correctly so now here's 75
[Music]
and once that feels easy I can bump it
up 15 again and at each stage I will get
comfortable with that tempo and
gradually move up until I find a tempo
where it's difficult and I start playing
in a sloppy way again then I can refine
move up eventually I reach my desired
tempo imagine you're ironing a wrinkly
shirt and you get through the whole
thing and when you're done you notice
there's still a wrinkle in the middle
and rather than just going right to that
spot and give me the wrinkle out you do
the entire shirt again hoping that when
you pass that spot it comes out this
time that would be a gigantic waste of
time right but unfortunately this is
exactly how most people practice they
play entire songs knowing full well that
there are spots that still have wrinkles
or didn't go well right problem spots
and rather than isolate in those moments
and working on them they get to the end
and they say well I guess I'll try the
whole thing again praying that it'll go
well this time so to fix this bad habit
we have to learn the difference between
practice mode and performance mode
practice mode is when we play through a
piece until we make a mistake and then
we stop and we work on that moment and
we try to figure out what went wrong we
work on it very slowly repeating it many
times until it's easy
[Music]
mistake right the scale wasn't clean so
now I could stop and say okay I'm in
practice mode so I need to actually work
on this bit and this is where I could
break out my metronome work through it
slowly and gradually speed it up in
increments of 15 BPM until I feel
comfortable to give it a run in the
actual piece better performance mode on
the other hand is when we play through a
song as if we're on stage playing for an
audience
[Music]
obviously there were several mistakes in
there but I didn't let them stop me and
I kept going as if I was in a
performance the point of performance
mode is to simulate the real experience
of performing to see how the piece would
go in public and to also ensure that we
don't accidentally stop just because of
one mistake so for now on you must know
which mode you're in at all times so you
can ask yourself these questions when
you sit down
am I just trying to play through this
piece for fun then performance mode is
great you could say am i trying to see
how this would go if I was to play in a
concert tomorrow performance mode again
however if you're trying to actually
improve the song then you have to be in
practice mode to practice well we need
to set easily achievable goals that can
actually be achieved in one sitting if
we make goals too big like become a
legendary guitar player there's no way
we can accomplish that and where do we
even begin right it's too ambiguous so
ask yourself this question instead what
am i struggling with the answer could be
if you're an electric guitar player this
guitar solo from a song by Metallica or
if you're a classical guitarist you
could be Capriccio or Ave by Francisco
de aragón now we're onto something so
let's say we picked Capri to rob a by
Targa as our weak song that we want to
improve we could start from the
beginning and just keep playing until we
hit a rough patch and let's say the
rough patch happened around measure 14
like this
[Music]
problem the slur wasn't very audible the
hammer-on wasn't very audible so we
could say okay stop everything let's fix
this there's a problem now we can say
well what if I just practice the slur by
itself I think that's the issue so you
could just dribble the slur for a while
thinking about how to make a better slur
turns out if your elbow is in the pinky
is stronger once that's one thing that
might help another complication here is
that your index finger has a giant
stretch you have to reach to the seventh
fret of the fifth string and hammer on
with your pinky to the twelfth so it
helps to divide the reach between the
fingers and straighten the pinky a
little bit to make the reach easier so
those are things you could discover
while practicing very slow and once you
think it's a bit better you could plug
it back in so so far we've diagnosed the
problem the hammer on is weak we've
worked on slowly repeating it to fix it
next step is backing up a bit and giving
it a running start to see if it's fixed
[Music]
that sounded good that time if it
doesn't sound good you need to go back
to step two where you work on that bit
very slowly figuring out what's the
problem how can I fix it okay so in
short goal-oriented practicing is when
you diagnose a problem then you isolate
that moment and repeat it very slowly
there's no such thing as too slow until
that moment feels easy then you give it
a running start to try it in context and
if it goes well great you're done if it
doesn't sound good still you need to go
back to step two and work at it very
slowly
analyzing huh what's the problem here I
mean if I go slower maybe if I change
the rhythm analyze it until you think
it's easier plug it back in to see if it
works keep doing this until the problem
goes away
and lastly most guitarists lack
structure in their practice routine so I
think you should get yourself a practice
journal this is mine I think you should
go buy a very beautiful nice journal
that is designated as your music book
and nothing else so in other words don't
be writing you know your grocery list
and doodles in here this is your sacred
music book and that's all so let's talk
about how to use our practice journal
effectively open to the first blank page
and write the date in the top left
corner and when we practice we're going
to log exactly what we do and how long
we do each thing so now I'm gonna give
you my templates of how I structure my
practice routine for the most progress I
always start with a warm-up then I go on
to work on some piece that needs
improvements and then lastly I always
end by reviewing songs that I already
know that I just want to play for either
enjoyment or just to make sure that I
still have them in my fingers
[Music]
March 24th 2020 warm-up spider crawl
chromatic scale string crossing exercise
with alternation in the right hand 10
minutes total by the way if you're not
warming up before you play your songs
you're doing yourself a disservice
please do check out my video on warming
up I did a whole video talking about
exercises and the purpose of warming up
it'll revolutionize your playing so
check that out in the in the description
below
next we can jump to a song and ease
improvements let's imagine we use the
example from today Capriccio harambe
by Francisco tárrega there was a moment
in measure 14 where that Heidi hammer-on
was no good so if I were to log that
moment it would say something like
playing through Capriccio arabe measure
14 needs work I I saluted the high e
slur playing it very slow many times
then I would put an asterisk every time
I make a discovery asterisk discovered
that if my elbow is in my pinkie
hammer-ons are stronger and then lastly
you could say review of repertoire so
you could play through songs that you
already know and like for a mixture of
enjoyment and a little bit of trial and
error to see if any of the pieces need
to be touched up at all but that part
can also be just an a way to end on a
positive note and remind yourself that
we're making music after all and it's a
beautiful thing okay so there we have it
five common practice mistakes that I
really wish I knew when I was younger
and now you know them so you can try to
avoid those bad habits and by the way I
want to emphasize that I still fall into
these bad habits constantly they're hard
to avoid it takes patience and
discipline to practice well but the
reward for good practice is endless
potential for your playing so stick with
it and good luck
thanks for watching I hope you found
this useful please do subscribe if you
haven't already to see more guitar tips
in the future and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]